[Music]
hi everyone thanks for joining me my
name is Ian Lake I am a developer on the
Android team and I work on quite a few
projects but most notably the navigation
architecture component as well as
fragments as well as some of our new
libraries like the Android X activity
artifact and loaders and today I want to
talk to you about single activity why
when and how and really try and share
some of the best practices from the
Android team and from the architecture
component team on what actually is going
on in this world
there's been a lot of questions way back
from 2014 16 and even here in 2018 so
we're here today to kind of talk over
all of those wonderful things that make
up what our activities so activities are
really a component at the android level
so they're at the same level as content
providers broadcast receivers and
services and they're registered in your
Android manifests and really they are
the UI facing pieces of your app right
so when the android framework goes to
start your application from launcher
icon or an app shortcut or what you see
when you're doing multi window those are
all activities right so they really are
kind of the entry point into your apps
UI right when the user goes to launch
your app they're launching an activity
and we had a very interesting quote from
Dianne Hackborn back in 2016 that once
we've gotten into this entry point to
your UI we really don't care how you
organize the flow inside 2016 and I
think it was controversial I guess in
2016 maybe we'll just say it had 77
comments on Google+ all right so
a lot of people were really enthusiastic
about this post but really like what
what does it mean right like well what I
think it means is that the framework
shouldn't care the framework shouldn't
care about your applications
architecture right it needs to provide
the hooks needed for the android
framework to start your application but
you should probably care about the
architecture if you're out that's why
you're all here today and I love having
you here so the biggest problem is that
you really don't know what an activity
is actually going to do so what's the
default animation for an activity well
it depends depends on the version of
Android what manufacturer you're on and
even what seems they've the user has
selected right so similarly we had
property animations that were added in
API 11 and they're much superior to view
animations and the thing is is that
while these new things become possible
on new versions of Android they're not
always applied to everything and things
like activities they don't support
property animations at all even today
and even if we were to add them in the
next version of Android maybe the letter
after P we wouldn't be able to back port
them because they're part of the
framework right so thinking about all
these things it's like well okay what
what should an activity be used for
right well why why do we even have
activities they're useful as this entry
point but then beyond that you're in
your realm right you're in your realm of
what your app needs to do and you don't
necessarily need to rely on activities
being the thing that you have to work
with so let's take an example here we
have some code like this we're calling
start activity and we have to use
activity compat because we want to
a shared element transition alright so
great our intent and then we say oh we
want to have this one element shared
well what API does actually work on well
it depends on what you mean by work
right it technically launches an
activity that's true
but it's only actually going to do a
shared element transition on newer
devices API 21 plus and really how many
compactions do we need in our life it
technically works you're saving some API
checks but really this isn't the
prettiest code to look at and similarly
are there any hidden gotchas right if
you are testing this on the latest
version of Android if you test it on an
older version of Android are you
actually going to get the same
experience well in this example I
actually ran into this and I was like oh
like well things are fading in and out
and like sure I chose fade but it turns
out you need to exclude things like the
status bar a navigation bar otherwise
still flicker and I was like well okay
well that's fun I wouldn't have ever
known that unless I tried it once and I
tried it on a whole bunch of different
devices and turns out on some devices
it's totally fine and other devices not
so much so there's a lot of little
hidden gotchas here that you can't
actually control or rely on in your app
another example where we have multiple
activities right and really each
activity is kind of its own component in
your app right so if you have two
activities and you want to share data
between them well there's not really a
scope for that there is a scope for that
but it's called your application scope
it's the same scope that's shared by
services and everything else in your app
but you really want kind of a shared
scope that's just within a couple of
components so this is a structure that
Android provides but it's maybe not the
one you actually want to use so what you
actually want is you want to build the
layering you actually need so in this
case we can have multiple things
multiple destinations within an activity
right and share in
across each of these destinations by
using the activity scope as an actual
useful element now so for example you
could have a shared view element or view
model that both destinations talk to so
one destination could put data in and
the other one could observe changes to
that data right you don't need to work
at the application scope level for this
to work so I mention this for a
destination so what is a destination
well really it's just a subsection of
your UI right so for most destinations
they're going to take over the majority
of your screen right like when you move
from one screen to the next screen in
your app it's gonna change the vast
majority of your screen right maybe you
have some global navigation like a
bottom nav or maybe you have an action
bar at the top but the rest of this is
all in a destination so the sub section
of your I we have a word for this it's
called a fragment but a fragments really
just one implementation of this idea of
having separate destinations for each
screen in your app and really this
fragment is serving as kind of the view
controller right the thing that isn't a
view itself but something that owns and
changes those views which are really
more about display all right so really
the activity instead of owning all of
this business logic and things like that
is really as small as is physically
possible and really only working on the
kind of that shared UI that's shared
across all destinations so what we're
thinking about this like if we're moving
from this activity world to a
destination rolled we really want to
make that world as easy as possible
right otherwise why it would be moved
and we focused on kind of two things one
was the that global UI kind of thing
like how can we make that part easy
right like it's something that every app
kind of has the same kind of patterns
and we really don't want that to be some
that takes a lot of effort to do
also the navigating between destinations
right that start activity activity
compat thing can we make that even
easier so we started the navigation
architecture component and we introduced
it to you all in IO this last year in
2018 it is still an alpha right now and
we're looking to fill out all the
feature gaps before taking it to 1.0
here soon but really what this allows us
to do is take a super simple activity
like this the content view will set us
action bar because that's a thing right
and we want to make this smart we want
to make this useful but we still want it
to fit on this one code slide so some of
this is we need a nav controller a nav
controller is really the heart of
navigation it's the thing that knows
everything about how your app works via
a navigation graph and we can get one
we're using Kotlin here column
extensions and call fine nav controller
and here we're just giving it the ID of
a nav host fragment the nav host
fragment is basically that part of your
UI that's going to change whenever you
change destinations we'll also add an
app bar configurations this is what
controls the up action and what needs to
happen when you move up from a
destination and how do we hook those up
nice one-liner that just says set up the
action bar gives us an app controller
and gives it an app bar configuration
now because we're using a drawer layout
here in our app bar configuration we
also want to open and shut the drawer
when you hit the UP button so we'll call
navigate up in our support navigate up
and we've set up our whole action bar
now it changes titles as our
destinations change we're good if we
want to add the navigation view and make
sure that we can click on things in our
side nav and they go to the right place
that's again one line because we can do
this all
because the nav controller knows about
our destinations in our app so then how
do we actually do navigate actions if
we're not doing fancy one-liner stuff
well we can get a nav controller from
basically anywhere if we're in our
activity news find nav controller it's
even easier from a fragment we can just
call find nav controller and we built
the Kotlin extension for this and
similarly even from a view any view
that's created by any fragment in your
navigation graph can just call find have
controller from a view so you have this
reference to it from basically anywhere
and we really tried to think alike all
right well you know if you have
arguments to something how do we make
this nice so we built a Gradle plugin
called safe args which for every
destination in your graph such as this
main fragment we generate a directions
object which has a nice simple show
profile method which gives you a
directions object with type safe
arguments that you define in your
navigation graph and then you just call
navigate and that's it will take care of
all of the fragment transaction and all
of that sort of stuff for you so this
makes a lot easier but we can really go
a lot farther with navigation so has
anyone ever built an intent filter
before deep linking in your app has
anyone enjoyed that experience great one
person enjoyed that experience and
really you have to do this because this
is what the android framework knows
right it knows I can par as an intent
filter and start an activity right but
in so oftentimes like that's not quite
enough I'm you need to go a little bit
farther right so what we've done in
navigation is for any one of your
fragments any destination in your graph
you can add a deep link it's a simple
one-liner and you can even add arguments
right here and we'll parse those out
even for things like query parameters
will parse those out and give you them
as arguments to your destination and
then because no one likes writing
intentional
elders will also generate the intent
filters for you by adding a navigation
graph so this was something we actually
added to manifest merger to kind of
generate that for you so all this
layering helps us build nicer api's but
it also makes it easier to test your
application right if you're testing at
the activity level all of a sudden that
means okay well how do I test that start
activity actually did the right intent
and we have to build extra testing
frameworks on top of testing frameworks
to try and mock out these things but if
we're moving towards more of a single
activity model into the navigation
controller world like we still want to
test all of those things we want that to
be easy to test so rule number one of
testing things at the destination level
is don't test at the destination level
it's really the number one thing with
testing right is making things nice and
separate and extracting some of that
business logic out of a destination and
into something you can test in isolation
right so example a view model is a
really nice place to put some of your
business logic because you can test it
in isolation
alright we have a view model provider
Factory for providing view models where
you can just inject things into your
view model test that totally separate
from your UI but that doesn't mean you
don't want to test any of your UI stuff
at all right we have espresso tests for
a reason right we want to make sure that
all parts of our app work well and are
testable so how can we do this
so last this Monday we released fragment
1.1 the first alpha and with this became
a new artifact called fragment testing
which is about like six years overdue
and it's really around being able to
test your Android X fragments in
isolation right separate from an
activity separate from everything else
but being able to test and verify that
that fragment
doing the right thing so super useful
for things like espresso tests where you
do want to test that logic right your
business logic separate object but your
UI logic right what happens when you
click that button is still something
that we want to verify is correct now
the nice part about this it's called
fragment scenario because it's actually
built on a different class called
activity scenario which is part of the
Android X testing team and actually the
testing team was instrumental in getting
fragment scenario out there but the best
part about this whole scenario is that
it works both on instrumentation tests
tests on your actual device and on
robolectric
so you get one test framework that works
on both of these so really exciting
opportunity and something that now you
can test with fragments so what does
this look like so let's say we want to
test our profile fragment right we did
our directions thing right we're passing
in a fake user ID here and we call
launch fragment in container not that's
it the this one line has both created an
empty hosting activity added the
fragment to it and waited it for it to
be resumed and now it's ready like you
can now use this fragment so if you want
to call on fragment and run some code on
your fragment and say like well is the
fragment in the right state great you
can do that here we're just gonna check
to see if our args are what we think
they are we've passed in a user ID we
can use the other half of safe args
using the args class another generated
class and just say like well is the args
user ID actually equal to the user ID we
passed in right did we not mess up on
all that sort of stuff but you can see
if you could run any logic any method on
your fragment right from here or we just
run espresso tests right you say is the
username actually equal to the user ID
we passed in right when we click the
subscribe button does it actually change
the text to subscribed right does it do
its thing right and all we can do this
with just that one line of launch
fragment in container four
the users it'll be fragment scenario
launch in container we obviously make
that a little bit nicer for you guys but
you don't test a fragment in isolation
because you know fragments do talk to
other fragments right and like I work on
navigation so there's that other bit of
testing of how can we test the links
between different destinations right
between different fragments and really
the nice part here that we have because
we're using these higher-level
components and not something like
activity is that we have unlockable
layer right one of the things that we
found when building navigation is that
most companies once they got to a
certain point and they're like wow we
should add some testing and they're like
wow we can't really test start
activities so they built their own
navigator which just provides a layer to
mock out the start activity calls
well that that layer is handled for you
it's called nav controller we test nav
controller so now what we can do in our
activities is just mock out that nav
controller and confirm that yes you're
calling the right navigate calls so here
we have our profile fragment again and
now it's getting our user ID and really
what we want to test is this on view
subscribers button alright so you could
tell like all right well we click this
and like oh my god it's like doing
something complicated in the fragment
how are we going to test this
here it's calling navigate right like
how can we make sure that this is
actually doing what we want it to do
well it's pretty easy we can do our
scenario thing just the same launch
fragment and now we can just mock out or
a nav controller and now you call on
fragment and what we're doing here is
actually just creating our own nav
controller right there's no nav host
here but we can just eject one right
this is actually what nav host fragment
is doing under the covers it's calling
sat nav controller on a view and saying
here's my nav controller but now
we've done is from this fragments point
of view it has a navigation controller
all those fine nav controls or calls
that normally you'd have to inject
something in to get your nav controller
now it just it just works like they're
in there right and now we can just run
espresso tests and say like click on the
view subscribers button and the nice
part is is that because we're using
these directions class we can use them
also in our tests and because they
implement equals we can just do a simple
verify and say verify did you actually
navigate to where we think you're
navigating all right and even if there's
a lot of parameters in there if there's
extras and other options in there we can
now just verify right and this makes it
so much easier to test those
interconnections between each
destination so nav controller is kind of
a special case because we find an app
controller right so many other things
aren't a service locator kind of pattern
it's we need to inject in those
dependencies and this is another one of
those like 6 years too late kind of a
thing
but we're finally working on it so
there's a class in Android P called app
component Factory
which allows you to construct activities
services broadcast receivers and
services all via dependency injection
right you get a chance of calling the
constructor instead of the system
calling your constructor same thing here
with fragments where now you can't
actually do constructor injection into
fragments right you no longer need to
only have a no args constructor to use
fragments you can use a fragment factory
to instantiate your fragments for you so
this is really useful also for cases
where your fragment was like casting
your activity to something I know we
probably still have a template that does
this we'll fix that and there's a lot of
ways where really we want to inject in
all of those external dependencies so we
can test
again in isolation and fragment factory
works great with our fragment scenario
so what does this look like we know how
to test a view model right it's just an
object you instantiate it you do the
thing and it has a real method called
subscribe right but really we want to
test our fragment and our fragment has a
non subscribed method that calls you
model dot Subscribe right and it does
its thing how do we get this view model
well we can inject the factory itself
inject the view model Factory and here
we're using some of the other new stuff
in fragment 1.1 this by view models
another collin property delegate that
does all that view model providers of
kind of stuff for you but we now have a
fragment that well we've injected
something but then we still need to test
like okay well did it actually call
subscribe right we're back to the same
situation of building testable code so
we can build a navigation activity this
is what it's going to look like in real
life right we're going to inject our
view model factory and then because code
is hard and I wanted to write things on
slides I built a helper class called an
initializer fragment Factory that
basically you just call add initializer
for each fragment and we call that
method to construct your fragment rather
than use the default no Arg constructor
so a little bit of magic there's a link
here if you want to check it out
we're looking at trying to integrate
this more deeply into the actual library
itself but once you've called this
fragment factory now whenever your
activity creates a profile fragment
instead of using that no art constructor
it's gonna use this constructor it's
gonna pass in our view model Factory
great
so our activity looks fine but our tests
how's that look well we create a mock of
our profile view model and then we can
set up a factory for it and then again
kind of use a fragment factory here that
again does the same type of thing where
we're passing in our mock view model
Factory and then our scenario looks
almost the same we just add it in and
add instead of just the arguments also
the fragment Factory great now we can do
our same thing on view perform the click
and then verify that yes are mocked out
view model did the SUBSCRIBE call
alright so now we have a testable
fragment a testable view model and we've
injected all of the dependencies into
our fragment all right we actually have
a testable thing now we are looking at
some improvements to this API because
you know we don't we want make this even
easier so in this case because we know
you're constructing a profile fragment
but we want to change this into is
actually something that looks like this
where you can say launch and then give
it a method saying oh like you launched
this fragment and specifically give it
the constructed out instance of your
fragment so you don't have to actually
know that oh it's using a fragment
factory under the hood you can test just
one fragment just fine now there are a
few cases where you might think oh man
maybe I do need multiple activities and
there's got to be reasons to use
multiple activities besides just
momentum right I understand a lot of
apps if you have multiple activities
right now this isn't actually an easy
sell right so there are a few cases
where even today we do recommend using
multiple activities not a lot though so
what I'd like to say is you don't
actually need multiply DVDs what you
need are multiple tasks so what are
tasks tasks are actually the thing that
users are actually interacting with so a
task is a stack of activities and each
task has a back stack so in your
overview menu here each one of these
entries
isn't just an activity it's actually a
whole task stack right so you're only
just seeing the topmost activity of that
stack right so each element here is a
stack right when you're doing split
screen multi tasks side-by-side right on
Chrome OS devices things that support
floating multi-window each one of these
tasks is a window it's a one-to-one
between windows and tasks not activities
and windows tasks and windows right so
launching a new task on one of these
Chrome OS devices gives you a new window
right so your app maybe it doesn't need
multiple activities but maybe it wants
multiple windows right so this is the
case where yes you need to use
activities under the hood each one of
these tasks is going to be a separate
activity but you may not use some of the
other things such as a stack of
activities in one task so what does this
actually look like a lot of this is that
there are a lot of different ways of
saying new tasks right has anyone looked
at all those wonderful launch mode flags
and all that fun yeah how many people
have you are still saying okay well I'll
say that there were a lot of good flags
out there in Android one they were great
back in Android one in today in 2018
they're maybe not the best thing to use
what you actually want to use is
document launch mode now document launch
mode was added actually an API 21 so
please like if you're thinking about pre
API 21 first what are you doing
and second probably try and steer away
from hacky solutions maybe it's just not
where
for those users but try and avoid things
like launch mode flags and task affinity
and those type of things because while
the framework does honor those maybe
doesn't honor them in the way you want
them to honor there's certainly a very
different kind of thing so what can you
actually do with document launch mode
well the biggest thing is multitasking
right if you can have multiple tasks
then you can have multiple windows right
you got multiple entries in your
overview screen so the first way of
really doing multitasking is into
existing now into existing basically
means whenever I launch this activity
that activity has its own task right
every time you launch this activity it
has its own task but if we already have
launched that task don't create a second
and a third copy right so this is really
useful for things like documents
conversations things where someone might
want to side by side compare two
different documents right if they're
copy pasting from one document to the
other
they're not gonna exit out of one dock
open one copy it and then open the other
one and then copy it into there right
this is kind of taking that multitasking
model that is Android that is that
recent screen and making it so that your
app actually gets to use this now of
course the into existing assumes you
have some notion of uniqueness right so
it does assume that from an intent
filter equals kind of point of view like
if you're using the data URI on your
activity that there is some sort of
unique ID write a conversation ID a
document ID something to uniquely define
that task in and of itself now one great
example of this that you can try out on
your phones is Google Docs so Google
Docs when you open a doc it actually
launches it in another task and if you
have multiple Doc's you can actually
load them up side-by-side on a phone two
different windows on a Chrome OS device
and
just works right even though it's one
app it can have multiple windows and
really allow a different level of
multitasking between different things so
another big one is creating new content
so new contents a little different
because there's not really any unique ID
right but you still want that kind of
multitasking behavior where you can
reference existing material while you're
creating something new all right so the
always flag is very similar to into
existing but it just always creates
something new right Wow it's like self
descriptive names we can do this guy's
and it allows you to do multiple things
at once right that's great
so one example this is Gmail so Gmail
actually uses this kind of mode when you
create a new email so this allows you to
create a new email and reference your
existing email at the same time magic
write it this is the equivalent on
mobile of when you do it on the web and
it pops up a little Mole that's separate
from the other one right you still need
that other material as reference even
when you're creating something new of
course on a phone or on a tablet it
looks slightly different the other case
is picture and picture now a picture and
picture actually has two entirely
separate modes for how you want to
approach picture and picture one is
using a separate task right this would
be a separate activity just for your
playback so this is really common on
Android TV devices for example Google
Play movies & TV uses this approach so
that you can actually put things into
picture in picture mode and then browse
through other movies so in this mode
it's very much that you have a specific
picture and picture mode button in your
UI the other mode is using just a single
task one activity right you actually
don't need anything at all here and this
is the approach the things like duo and
Google Maps use where your whole task is
becoming the picture-in-picture
right so when would you want to choose
one or the other and it's really this
case where once I'm in
picture-in-picture mode if they were to
click my launcher icon what would happen
because the launcher icon always
launches the default task right of your
app so in duos case where they only have
one task when you launch that duo from
your launcher icon it's just going to
pop open the picture-in-picture you go
from a little tiny picture picture to
full screen because it doesn't make
sense to have multiple conversations
going at the same time you're never
going to replace one with the other
you're never going to continue to
reference something even though
something is already going alright so
that's kind of the differentiator here
where do you want to be able to browse
and picture and picture at the same time
if you do want to browse then yes you're
using the android framework and
therefore they need to position those
separately two separate tests separate
activities but that's that's kind it the
one thing I didn't mention are things
like instant apps now in synapse kind of
works at the activity level right you
call startactivity it downloads your
instant at module but there's actually
some really exciting things that are
being worked on by the Play team I think
there was a talk here at Android dev Sun
but a lot of it is around the instant
experience for your app bundle making
your whole app instant and also dynamic
feature modules now these are really
interesting ways of adding things on to
the thing that don't require a specific
app architecture to implement right we
can't actually do more things with this
so for the instant experience it's
adding this distribution instant equals
true and this means that someone can try
your entire app write your entire base
module all one's totally instant right
and this works really well with things
like app links so those deep links that
I
said you could add to any destination
you can also make them into app links by
adding the Auto verifiable true and that
means you skip the disambiguation and
when someone launches your a deep link
on the web they're going to open up your
instant app experience right they're
going to download that whole base module
for you and your whole navigation graph
is already there ready to go
but this doesn't work if your app is too
large right so you want to dynamically
deliver things that are not used very
often or rather big things right that's
what dynamic feature modules are all
about about being able to download them
on demand now the really interesting
part about dynamic feature modules is
that you're adding classes right you
don't need to add activities you could
add just destinations just a number of
fragments all right so in this case you
can add new destinations on demand just
because you've built out a XML file for
your navigation graph statically each
one of these dynamic feature modules can
also add their own navigation graph so
this means that we're not tied to
separate activities we can now actually
still use one activity now there's still
more to be done here both on the play
side and on the navigation side but we
want to make this really easy for
developers to use so what we want to get
to is where you can add something to
your navigation graph with just a
feature tag just like you'd add a
fragment tag or something like that and
when you navigate to this destination
that's actually going to do all of the
downloading and making your feature
module available from whatever your
split name is so that's the world we
want to get into where you can use a
single activity where you can use a lot
of the useful things like deep linking
and navigation without necessarily
contorting your app architecture around
everything else so
really like to end this with OneNote a
lot of you have existing apps that have
very different kind of experiences and
I'd like to say do what's right for your
app I think single activities great I
was writing a new activity it would also
be single activity but I realize that
doing going to your p.m. and be like hey
let's rip the whole app apart is
sometimes a hard sell some of them don't
like your current app so maybe you'll
actually get some yeah okay go for it
really depends on your own experience if
you find yourself contorting your own
experience and it's not making sense to
you don't do it right if something is
working that's good keep it working
right but if you're finding you're
running into issues you're having
inconsistent behavior right or you want
to do things like share a few models
maybe that's the time to think about
moving towards a single activity
structure so thank you QA your outside
really appreciate you all coming
[Music]